and when you see a big company like
1-800 Flowers or Heineken so a company
that has millions of customers when they
say one or two lines like that
that gets me really interesting
[Music]
all right we're live Sean is not here so
I'm gonna do a question and answer
session I tweeted out that I'm going to
be doing this and we have a bunch of
questions Jonathan's going to be reading
uh the first ones what are they which
where do you want to start
all right this one is from Jimbo slice
at J Gilly three he goes would love to
learn how to develop ideas for
businesses to start and how to test said
ideas so basically because of this
podcast I have to research cool
companies but what a lot of people don't
know is I've been doing research on
companies before I worked on this
podcast before I started this podcast
and this is how I created the hustle we
ended up selling the hustle for tens of
billions of dollars and this is how he
created Hampton which is going to be a
huge company I think and I've done a
bunch of other little projects based off
of this research model
um I'll do a quick plug basically if you
go to ideationbootcamp.com everyone kept
asking me about this process so I like
made it into a course you can go and buy
it if you want I'll just kind of give
you a little preview now I've got this
way of researching where I look for
five or six different things and it's
almost like the way that I compare it to
a song so there's a song called uh uh
you know like a Guns and Roses song like
Welcome To Paradise is that what it's
called Sweet Child of Mine that's what
I'm thinking Sweet Child of Mine Sweet
Child of Mine has this amazing guitar
solo uh in that song and the the band
said that someone asked them how they
write songs they're like well sometimes
like which Sweet Child of Mine I heard
this uh amazing guitar riff that slash
was tinkering with and I wrote lyrics
around it and then we created the bridge
and the hook and whatever other times
I've got this really cool one-liner this
lyric we're gonna turn it into the song
I do the same thing with business and so
those little hooks that I look for are
the first thing is demand so I'm
constantly seeking out what problems
people have
uh the second thing is I'm constantly
looking at uh how many people share that
particular problem and I'm gonna give
examples of all this the third thing I
look at is who are the leaders in that
space so what's succeeding and why the
fourth thing I look at is of the leaders
and the people in the space What
shortcomings do they have
next I look at which business models are
most effective
and then finally I look at what problems
aren't being solved and I'm going to
give you an example of this and so I
have all these tools that I use and so
like here's a here's an example
so there's there's this company called
1-800 Flowers and
um it's a phone service where you call
and you order flowers and I was just
like probably buying Valentine's Day
flowers on their website one time and I
noticed that their traffic I use this
tool called similar web I use that all
the time it's a plug-in it's free they
have a paid version the free versions
totally fine they have this plug-in
where it tells you a guesstimate of what
the traffic is from a website and 1-800
Flowers as predicted it had like pretty
great traffic like it was like five
million people a month coming to the
website and then in February it like
peaked to be really really big that's
easy to guess because it was Valentine's
Day but basically
it was that told me that wow A lot of
people are using 1 800 Flowers on a
regular basis and it peaks in February
and they also uh had a big jump in uh
um whenever Mother's day is May or June
and so I was like all right that's
interesting I kind of knew that but let
me read a little bit more about this and
so I use another tool called
annualreports.com and I love reading
annual reports because it teaches me
about the company so an annual report if
a company is public they have to release
this quarterly report where they talk
about
their earnings and all these interesting
things about the company and a lot of
time they appear boring but I'm reading
them to find insight and I found this
one Insight that said
we are noticing that the the succulent
plant it's a very particular plant we
are noticing that amongst our Millennial
consumers it's the fastest growing trend
I also did this with Heineken the
company Heineken they in their annual
report they said
um Heineken zero so which is like a
non-alcohol version
they are uh it's our fastest growing
segment it's still really small but it's
fast growing and when you see a big
company like 100 flowers or Heineken so
a company that has millions of customers
when they say one or two lines like that
that gets me really interested when they
say something's fast growing I'm like oh
I'm intrigued and so I'll read these
reports just for looking for one or two
lines that say that or I'll use I'll go
to like every website I go to if it's
like really weird looking
um and it grabs my attention I go to a
similar web and I just look at what the
traffic is because I'm looking for these
one little tidbits that catch my
attention and in this case for the 1-800
Flowers it they said succulents were
growing and so I'll look at
um
you know what they say and and then I
try to find shortcomings so with 1-800
Flowers they said that their
shortcomings are they uh that most of
the revenue comes from holidays and so
they're trying to get revenue and
business between the holidays to make
their business more steady they also
said that I believe this was a few years
ago they said that most of their profit
comes from not the flowers but from
vases so that has the biggest margins
and they also said uh that they're
trying to think of ways to get people to
buy more accessories like vases
chocolates and things like that and then
uh so that kind of like gave me this
idea of like okay 100 flowers is a big
business because the revenue is huge and
it gets tons of traffic I know that so
that's like proving me that there's
demand and a big audience I know that
they're succeeding at least to some
point because they're a publicly traded
company and they're very profitable I
know they're shortcomings or the
problems that they're trying to solve
for are that they uh can't get people to
buy stuff on a regular basis and they
want people to buy more vases so what
other problems are consumers not being
uh not do consumers have that aren't
being solved and where's 100 flowers
failing well in my head I was like well
if you could figure out a way to get
people to buy regularly with different
vases how can I do that and so I wrote
this report
for Trends trends.co and then someone
eventually launched a company where they
created this succulent plant that you
like smack on the wall and it's like has
this like hydrophonic system Panic
system where like it like watered itself
and then there was another company that
launched and they and they created the
coolest it was a succulent plant and all
some of them launched these companies
based off our that report I wrote
another company created this uh business
where they had these like amazing pots
and vases why I had like artists on
there so like Frida Kahlo was on one or
they would create like really funny
pots and plants like some of the pots
were like State themed so like an organ
plant like had had like an organ flag on
the vase like things like that and that
was their way of solving it and a bunch
of these companies a few of them went on
to raise millions and millions of
dollars I think there's bloomscape and I
forget the other one but
it basically came from this like
research methodology of finding demand
finding the audience looking at the
leaders the shortcomings and it's this
like cycle that I use and I try to find
like one hook or one line for each of
those things that get me interested so I
use similar web a ton to do that so I
look at where someone's getting a lot of
traffic or how much traffic's getting
there's another amazing thing called
companies house it's a so basically if
you're based in the UK and you're a
company that does at least 10 million in
Revenue you have to file your um
your uh financials and so if I find a
cool company that uses the word LTD I
guess that means like limited company if
I find a company that does something
like that has that on their website I
immediately go to companies house but so
for example I found this amazing website
that basically basically was reviewing
um vpns you know what a VPN is it's like
a thing that hides like where you are
when you're using the web and they have
like 12 million visitors to their site
and I was like oh that's interesting and
the company was called like something
company name LTD so I go all right I'm
gonna go straight to companies house and
see what the revenue is their revenue
was like 18 million and their profit was
like 16 million and so that told me that
hey there's demand for people who want
to uh
get reviews for VPN that shocks me I
didn't realize that market was that Big
B it shows me that that business model
of affiliate so they made money through
affiliate so they would write a review
on a um
they would write a review on a VPN if
someone bought it they got a little
cutback that business model super
fascinating so in my head I'm like oh
wow what other Tech products are have
this big affiliate fees and can I create
content for them that business model was
really fascinating and see I learned
that they were the leader in the space
and so like that just like opened up my
mind to like a different business model
and a different Niche and I didn't do
anything with that but I thought to
myself man I wonder if I could do this
for payroll software I wonder how many
people are having payroll software
problems uh I bet you I can get a big
affiliate fee with that I bet you I
could rank on search for that and then
I'd never end up doing it because I
wasn't passionate about it but anyway I
go through all these different examples
and of like these different tools that I
use to research on Aviation bootcamp
it's auditionbootcamp.com but that's
like a very
scattered example of how I do that all
right this one is from Mike taravella he
asks about the evolution of your health
Journey while being an entrepreneur he
goes I've been lifting to get back in
shape and just curious of lessons or
future roadblocks to watch out for so
this is around fitness and health so let
me give you guys some background so I
was an exceptional High School athlete I
was one of the best in the state of
Missouri where I'm from at the 200 meter
and 400 meter dash and then I went to a
division one school where I was a
scholarship athlete for two years and
then I quit and I got into business and
between the ages of 20 to about 28 I was
fat I was pretty lumpy and I was pretty
disgusting now is a good time to put the
my before picture
so if you're on uh listening to this on
audio you can go ahead and see you can
go to our YouTube and see those pictures
but I got pretty fat and I got
disgusting and then about three or four
years ago I said this is it I'm gonna
get my act together and I'm gonna become
a fitness model that's what I said it
was a joke I'm not actually that but it
was a joke and I did it I got pretty fit
and so I basically created this rule uh
General Mathis he's this uh General in
America he's got this great line that
says figure out your flat ass rolls and
stick to them and the reason being and I
saw this from Ryan holiday who's uh
inspiration to me he said the person who
decides every day uh what choices they
have to make for each decision that
person will be exhausted and burnt out
and so about when I was 29 28 years old
I made the decision that I will never
ever ever miss a workout
and so at first I basically created
programming for myself which means I
created my own schedule my own lifts and
like how much I should lift I did that
on my own for a little while and then I
hired a trainer his name is Jesse
O'Brien at Central athlete I think go to
centralathlete.com you can see them I'm
not affiliated I'm just a fan and he
created all my training for me and I
meet with them monthly and I do the
workouts remotely but basically I don't
miss a single workout and I have uh I
work out five days a week and I so
that's five days times 52 I think that's
260 workouts in the last two years three
years I've probably have missed five to
ten a year and that's usually only
because of sickness or like if someone
dies and I have to take a flight to a
funeral but basically 95 of the time I
don't miss and so I believe big big big
and big time into consistency and so I
don't miss the second thing that I do
and by the way that like that I'm fairly
extreme about it so for example uh I
drive a ton so like when I go and I take
tons of road trips when I take a road
trip and I can't get my workout in the
morning before I leave I pull over on
the side of the road I tell Jesse
today's a travel day I'm gonna be
driving and I bring uh bands with me and
I pull over on truck stop I got lots of
pictures and videos of me setting my
wife saying uh I'm at this particular
truck stop I'm doing push-ups burpees
Sprints things like that I'll pull over
on the side of the road for an hour and
do it I do not miss workouts the second
thing that I do is I set very specific
goals so each quarter I have a new goal
so those goals have included like I
wanted to bench press 330 pounds and I
wanted to squat 430 pounds and I I'll
take a quarter sometimes two quarters to
get there the next time I've had a goal
of doing a combine and I wanted to score
average for an NFL receiver uh which I
think was like a four five forty a 34
inch vertical a 10 4 broad jump and then
bench pressing 225 pounds times
16 times I think whatever it was I pick
goals every quarter and I stick to them
because I I need to have a goal I don't
always hit my goal sometimes I most the
time I do but I but I I always have a
goal that I'm trying to do
for me right now and I imagine for the
rest of my life it's gonna all be
centered around weightlifting because a
I want to live to like I'm 130 and there
seems to be a strong correlation between
living long and uh having muscle like
because it I can just not break my hip
when I fall because my bones will be
stronger and I can get up when I get
hurt
um and also B because I want to look
good naked I'm vain so that's why I do
it so I lift a ton of weights and I have
a coach that tells me what to do and I
basically don't question them I also use
my body tutor no affiliation with them
other than I've become friends with them
and that helps me with my dieting so I
spend roughly 300 a month on training
and I think 250 a month on my body tutor
it's basically a nutritionist and they
call me once a week and they keep me on
track and then finally I write down
everything I eat and I write down every
workout so I use an app where I track
all of my workouts uh because I want to
know what I did the previous week so I
can improve and then I track everything
I eat because it's really easy for me to
overeat and so
tracking it helps me
um this person asked um
what future roadblocks will be everyone
I don't have a kid yet I but we are
pregnant everyone says that that will be
a roadblock I'm in a very fortunate
situation where I've been able to hire
some help like a night nurse and things
like that I have a feeling that it won't
be a roadblock but I it will be more
challenging but it's not going to
prevent me did I answer that question
yeah for sure all right this one is from
John Murphy at Ecom CEO he asks when to
embrace shiny object syndrome and when
and how to keep it under control this is
a great question and this is something
that I think holds back 90 of people
from really big success so I constantly
ask myself what can I do this week this
month this year
what can I accomplish in a certain time
period that will make every other task
not important and so there's this idea
of like procrastination Paul Graham
wrote this great article if you Google
Paul Graham procrastination he talks
about there's actually good
procrastination there's bad
procrastination procrastination the bad
type is
um you're just not gonna you just don't
start working but the good type is that
it's like the idea of this crazy
scientist who's a genius and he forgets
the shower or he forgets to wear two uh
matching socks and the idea being is you
can actually ignore most things as long
as you're getting the big things right
and so I ask myself all the time
what is that one thing that I want to
accomplish most people they try to jump
from thing to thing to thing because
something's not working or because they
feel pressured into doing something I
actually think that you should do one
thing for an extended period of time the
reason being is because
every time I say yes to something I'm
ultimately saying no to something else
and that means I'm saying if I'm saying
yes to a new project I'm saying no to
either things like family time or I'm
saying no to focusing on the thing that
matters or I'm saying no to having like
I'm basically giving worry uh or uh
worry time and I'm giving
uh space in my brain for something that
isn't essential and so saying no is
really important it's very uncomfortable
but I think it's necessary I think most
people do multiple things at one time
because they are guilted into it because
what they see online
um and I try to remind myself that I
don't care about another person's
opinion more than I care about my own
opinion and also most people don't know
what they're doing and so I'm not going
to put too much judgment on
their opinion because they don't have
any idea what they're doing I also try
to remind myself that strong men
they don't like give in to fear and I
think a lot of people have shiny object
syndrome because they're fearful that
their main thing's not going to work I
try not to give into fear of course I'm
human I do every once in a while but I
try my hardest not to do it and so I
think that
when you're starting a business because
it's a business podcast we'll talk about
that
I I have to ask myself well I wish that
I have stuck with this in 10 years well
I look back and say I wish I would have
done this one thing and if the answer is
consistently yes then I'm going to stick
to that one thing that said it's
definitely an art to figure out what to
say no to and when to bail on what's
working but I've met a lot of successful
people
and I've noticed
that the people that have huge outside
outsized results
and have massive massive wealth it
typically comes from one thing and then
once they get incredibly successful it
appears as though they have a lot of
things going on but those a lot of
things are like five percent of the
hundred percent when it comes to net
worth creation
and so I have to remind myself on a
regular basis that big results typically
come from one thing and the people who
appear to be to be doing a lot of things
they actually kind of are doing one
thing one of my good friends Andrew
Wilkinson he owns a private Equity
company or he owns a thing called tiny
where they buy businesses and so he owns
technically like 40 businesses
but his one thing is buying companies or
investing and so you have to remind
myself I have to remind myself that's
just one thing and he's doing that well
and that's what makes everything else
work additionally he also had one agency
meta lab for I think 12 years and then
he started investing into other
companies and so you have to make your
one thing work otherwise the rest of the
stuff doesn't really work out and so I
think more people should focus even
though it's quite challenging and it
doesn't appear as fun
I think it's better results
okay this one is from Gabe finnema at
Gabe underscore Finn on Twitter he asks
how to be interesting as a podcaster
you're essentially a professional
Entertainer what are the key skills
you've learned over the years that allow
you to be entertaining to listen to and
talk to
this question is I think particularly
interesting for young men single men
because when I was a single guy when I
was 14 15 and 16 well
basically until I was not single all I
cared about was meeting girls and what I
learned and I wasn't very good at it
arguably was never great at it but I
improved the best thing for meeting a
partner was to be an interesting person
I imagine this works for women as well
but I only know a man's perspective it
works awesome for men it's to be
interesting
um
I made a few points about how to be
interesting at least what I think
got to be interesting because I like
figured this out I wasn't like good at
this
the first thing is that you have to find
something that interests you and you
have to turn it into a passion even if
it's not popular
the reason being is people like people
who uh are passionate about stuff and
who are really great at explaining why
they're passionate about things and they
don't need to be popular things so for a
long time I'm I was really interested in
denim that's like a hobby of mine I love
genes because genes are part of American
history and I would like buy like 500 or
a thousand dollar jeans just to store
them and keep them and only wear them
occasionally because they're historical
and important to me I was really really
fascinated in that and I noticed that
when I would meet a girl and I would say
something like hey I'm going to this uh
swap meet they got really cool denim
just having something to do and like
being passionate about it it attracts
she was more attracted to me because of
it and then my male friends as well were
like oh this sounds interesting you just
got me interested in this topic I'll go
with you and you could explain it to me
and thus people were attracted to me
this works for business for meeting
someone whatever right now it's Fitness
I'm super fascinating Fitness and having
like a goal and having
something I care about I've noticed
people are drawn to me the second one is
when I can I consume a ton of
information so I listen to podcasts I um
watch a lot of TV like documentaries I
read a lot of books and I read Wikipedia
every night I love Wikipedia and when
I'm consuming information
I consume it from the perspective of I
try to find a hook so I'll hear like or
I'll read something on Wikipedia and I
try to find a fascinating hook and I
think in my brain how can I retell this
that can capture people's attention and
whenever I consume information that's
what I do so for example I just watched
the documentary on Arnold Schwarz
Schwarzenegger and he has this great
line where he calls the shmee which
basically means so like when he
was talking about being the spokesperson
for supplement brands or whatever or uh
whining and dining people he goes I got
the schmee I know how to like grab
people's attention I'm just bullshitting
with them I got to get the Gap and he
told the story of the shmee and I
remember hearing that line I go that's
brilliant the schmee I'm going to talk
about that all the time I love the shmee
and that was that one little line I took
from that documentary and I'm going to
retell that story all the time I'm going
to talk all about the shmee and so
whenever I consume information I'm just
or a comedy show or anything I just look
for like lines or hooks of a story that
I'm going to retell to people constantly
I'm gonna steal it basically it does it
I can consume information as if I have
to write a book report at another time
the third thing is I ask people all the
time and I ask them this in a very
non-judgmental way and a lot of people
aren't used to being asked this but I
basically asked them all the time
whenever they I'll ask him
about what they do for work or where
they're from or whatever
and they'll say something and they'll
say an opinion and I always ask them why
do you think that and I always try to
ask that because it gets people to open
up and when I ask them all about
themselves there's this uh great book uh
called How to Win Friends and Influence
People and Dale Carnegie wrote it in the
1920s and he says this tells a story
about
this kind of nobody young guy talking to
this big shot executive and the nobody
guy the young guy he asked the big shot
executive all about himself and the
executive spends 95 of the conversation
talking all about himself the young guy
spends five percent of the conversation
at the end of the conversation the
executive goes wow you're a great
conversationalist and the truth is that
that's because people love to talk about
themselves and so oftentimes when I'm
with new people I'll ask some questions
like why do you think that or why do you
do that or questions like that these
open-ended questions and that gives them
an opportunity to talk about themselves
and thus they think that I am more
interesting because ultimately they find
themselves probably more interesting
than anyone else
another thing is I have tried really
hard to learn how to tell stories my
partner in this podcast Sean Perry he's
one of the best storytellers uh I've
seen
um I've tried to learn from him and I've
tried to tell stories and I'll retell
the same stories to different groups of
people as if I'm a comedian and I like
to see what hits and what doesn't and
sometimes I'll alter the story while
keeping the truth in there but I'll also
the story in the way I tell it in order
to capture their attention
the last two things are I am constantly
trying to improve myself which is great
because to be interesting you just make
yourself better so I'm constantly trying
to improve myself and I explain to
people what I'm trying to do so for
example if I'm trying to get fit if I'm
trying to read a certain amount of books
if I'm trying to uh build a business I'm
always trying to improve myself and I
talk about that with people not in an
obnoxious way but I let them know and
they find that interesting I found most
of the time and then finally I say my
opinion and I usually research opinions
that I have so for example it could be
like political stuff it could be Health
stuff it could be in business I try to
come up with the well thought out
opinions and I'm very uh not afraid to
say that opinion and even if it rubs
people the wrong way I have found that
when you explain your opinion and you
stand firm on it uh it you people find
you interesting because most people are
vanilla and they don't have strong
opinions and so
that said I'm still open-minded I think
there's a phrase what's that phrase It's
a strong beliefs loosely held and so I'm
I can be swayed for sure but I have
strong opinions and I try to let people
know about them and then when I don't
have an opinion or I haven't researched
a topic I try my hardest to say
I've not thought about that or I don't
know
um and so that's how I think you'd be
interesting when we have different
podcast guests come on
even if they're not in my world at all
because I've like consumed so much
information I'm pretty good at relating
to them and that is just comes down to
I just read a ton of Wikipedia and when
they talk I'll reference things in that
field even if I don't know a ton about
them and then I'll ask them why they
think that because I read on Wikipedia
that this this and this
um is that true for you is does that uh
is that one of the reasons why you think
X Y and Z and they'll say no actually or
Yes actually and that's a great way to
get them to talk more about it and it
gets me involved in the conversation
[Music]
you heard of HubSpot see most trms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better
all right so I back channeled a few
questions this one is from your buddy
Neville madora at Neville madora on
Twitter and he wanted to hear a bit
about your loyalty to your dog Sid he
had a quote to share that I thought was
pretty great he goes I remember Sam
vividly saying I hate when people give
away their pets when you sign up for a
dog you sign up for life so Neville
wants to hear a bit about your
relationship to Sid and just if you
could elaborate on that quote a bit Yeah
so basically I have this dog named Sid I
got him when I was 20 or 22 or something
he's 14 years old now and I do crazy
stuff for this dog like for example I
live half the year sometimes in New York
and sometimes I'll fly sometimes I'll
drive but if I fly I hire a driver for
him so I basically hire someone to drive
him from
Austin all the way up to New York
and like I don't travel because of him
uh overseas typically and so the reason
being is I mentioned uh having rules
another rule in my book is
responsibility and loyalty so there's a
few people in my life my wife my dog my
business partner Joe Sean's one of these
folks Jordan the CEO of Hampton
I firmly believe that you never ever
ever speak badly about them behind their
back you don't lie you don't disrespect
them publicly you don't question them
publicly and I try my hardest not to do
that even a little bit the reason being
is uh I'm a firm belief in loyalty and
so uh there's I basically have zero
loyalty to most people and then there's
like eight people in my life my life who
I like I can like write them down and
cite them I will do anything for them
and I expect them to do that for me
the second reason is responsibility so
like when I have a meeting on my
calendar
I try my hardest never ever ever to be
late I try very hard to be early I don't
miss things if I say I'm going to do
something I do it I'm a big firm
believer and you do what you say and uh
following through and so another rule is
when you have a responsibility you stick
with it no matter what when I got my dog
I said I'm gonna raise them right and uh
I'm gonna like respect this this like
bond that we have and so I'm crazy about
that so that's a rule that I just don't
break is loyalty and uh rules
love it all right this one is from
Garrett's his handles at ggs III and he
goes finding someone to build a company
with or finding your first hire so
basically he's just asking how you hire
people
so I'm not like a religious person but
there's this uh thing from the Bible I
went to Catholic School in my life
there's this like a line from the Bible
where like Jesus is trying to like get
disciples and he tells one of his
disciples Peter and Paul he goes like I
think they're fishermen and goes come
join me and you're going to be Fishers
of Men uh and I love that line
um that's an example by the way of being
interesting you just find like
interesting lines and you you know you
retell them that's a beautiful line and
the way that I'm able to hire good CEOs
and hire great people I mean if you look
at the hustle
I don't know how many people we had when
we sold the company maybe 40 so we
probably have hired 60 or 70 people
a lot of them are really successful now
like we hired them when they were like
23 and a lot of them maybe like 15 or 20
of them have went on to start successful
companies help grow other successful
companies have a name for themselves and
the reason they did that is I wanted to
be a collector of people Fishers of Men
that's a weird line I call it collector
of people so I worked really hard at
collecting people and so
when I find someone that's interesting
to me
um I try to make a mental note of who
they are and how I can use them and the
line that I tell them
and this is the line that I believe
which is like hey do you want to hang
out like let's say I meet someone I'll
follow up with them or I cold email
someone and I'll say hey look the best
case scenario here is that somehow we
work together and we create Magic the
worst case scenario is that you have a
new friend in the industry and we'll
just help one another but our world is
small and I have a feeling that it's
gonna be nice that we're going to be on
the same team in some capacity whether
just as friends or literally at the same
company so
take this phone call and that's what I
believe and so uh for years so like for
example
for years I would host events or create
excuses to meet people so for example I
had this thing called the anti-mba it
was my book club I started it in San
Francisco in 2012 and basically the way
it worked is I would pick one book per
month we would read a quarter of the
book each month and then we would meet
up and talk about the book and I would
bring experts on that book's topic to
come in and lead the conversation so
it's kind of like an MBA but it was free
and I organized it hence the anti-mba a
bunch of my great great friends uh Sean
and uh Perry we we came in each other's
orbit via this book club
um cieva who um kazinski who's got a
really successful PE firm now came he
was one of my first members I posted ads
on Craigslist for this book club that's
how it got Popular by the way I posted
an ad on meetup.com and on Craigslist
and I would Host this book club like one
I think I did it for two years straight
every week
and that is how I developed a network
and then from there I hosted a
conference called hustlecon and the
whole idea was I'm not sure what I'm
going to do next after selling my
previous company but I'm gonna Host this
event called hustlecon and in doing so I
imagine I'm gonna meet a handful of
people who will inspire me or partner
with me in order to create my next thing
and so I'm constantly I do it less now
now I I jokingly have this rule called
No New Friends because I have a pretty
good Network now but basically I just
collected people and anytime I saw
someone who was intriguing I did a
really good job of getting to know them
and then just filing them away in this
bank or I would check in with them once
in a while and get to know them uh and
remind them who I was occasionally and
then when I had like an opportunity like
I'm starting a new company I would think
oh I talked to this one person this one
time I left a good impression on them I
hope I could just holler at them and so
I do a really good job of collecting
people and doing Outreach
um
uh yeah I mean that's kind of like how
it works it's a lot easier now that when
you're popular and you have a podcast
it's way easier to do that but when I
was younger and didn't have a network I
hosted book clubs conferences meetups
and I was basically wanting to be the
center of attention not necessarily a
center of attention but the center of a
Social Circle uh and I was the connector
and that's how I would collect people
and I um when I sleep now when I see
people on LinkedIn or Twitter
and they write something cool I DM them
and all I say was like saw this post
this was awesome and that's all I'll say
uh and then when I reach out to them
again if I ever have a reason to it kind
of feels like they know me a little bit
at least
and so I'm a collector of people
okay this question is from Grant
Wilkinson at Grant F Wilkinson if you're
open to sharing about the behind the
scenes of running a great Community
there's some good stuff there so I think
Grant's referring to uh your community
building over at Hampton
so I've got this new company it's about
a year old it's uh joanhampton.com is
the URL it's called the Hampton
basically what it is is
it's for CEOs who have at least a
million in revenue and you apply and
then we interview you get in we put you
in a group of eight Founders who have
similar size and types of businesses you
meet monthly and then we host all these
events Retreats and then we have uh
digital Community where you can hang out
and talk to all the other members of
which we have hundreds of them soon
thousands
I I got pretty great at
making Community because of the events
that I hosted I kind of understood like
what motivated people and then I created
trends when we ran the hustle which was
like a digital Community as well
and there's a few interesting things
about Community to make them great the
first is
you have to create fomo so a little bit
of fear of missing out and once they're
in your community they feel excited that
they're finally in and so we create fomo
not even on purpose we interview
everyone and we turn down most people so
that helps
um so there needs to be a barrier to
entry for building a good Community I
think there also has to be a way to
create intimacy
and so there's lots of tactical ways
that you could do that where you have
multiple communities within a community
and like you can only Join one
Channel and not the other channels and
the reason you do that is because I
think that around like 250 500 people
things get a little bit wonky in terms
of not being able to know everyone and
so you want to do you need to do a good
job of making things intimate the way
you do that is to keep it small another
way that you do that is you set norms
and standards behind introductions and
so at Hampton we do a really good job of
saying
look at Hampton
we want you to brag about who you are
because with most most of the times when
you run a company it's not cool when
you're talking to people that say like
oh I run this company we do this much in
Revenue this much profit this many
employees it's not that cool it's all
Tacky in this community we set lots of
like strange Norms of which one of them
is it's okay to brag and it's cool to
brag because now I can learn if you
actually know what you're talking about
and I can ask you advice I can actually
learn
um
about your business so I can apply some
of it and so it's fun to learn that
stuff and so we set different norms and
we do a really good job of making people
introduce themselves a lot of times
particularly in Trends my one of the
first communities that I built I would
seed it by having 10 20 30 people who I
knew were impressive and I just said you
don't have to pay anything but you're
joining this community also on this date
I need you to post this comment or this
uh post
and so it looks like this particular
person was contributing in reality I
wrote it for them this is a thing that I
stole from Reddit when reddit.com first
launched the founder Steve Huffman
created like 30 different usernames and
he just posted lots of different fake
comments and it looked like a lot of
stuff was happening creating Community
is hard I think it's one of those things
that everyone wants but few people know
how to do it's really challenging I
think it's more art than science though
this question is I'm going to totally
butcher this name but sarong birad at
sarong birad on Twitter he asks how's it
going with viral Cuts share some tips
for someone looking to start a
productized service from scratch so
viral Cuts is a company that I'm part of
um I don't have anything to do with the
day-to-day but basically if you want
footed like if you have a podcast like
this or if you have a bunch of video
footage they chop it up
and they uh post it on your social for
you so you get like clips
um the founder his name's Hunter he used
to have an agency and he was like you
know it's cool agencies are great but
when your agency is really Broad and you
will do lots of services for lots of
different uh clients
and it's hard to focus on something it's
hard to operationalize something your
margins kind of get crushed a little bit
and it's just a lot more challenging and
so his whole thing was we're just gonna
do clips and then eventually now they're
doing more stuff under a different
company like they're doing um they're
helping people write uh books or uh
write Twitter threads I mean they're
helping people do a bunch of different
stuff um they're helping people grow
their YouTube but those are all
different companies but viral Cuts he
was like I'm just going to productize
this one service and so he did a really
good job of hiring like 20
people and he taught them how to make
the the the clips and then he like
created a very strict process on how to
get the footage from people how to chop
it up how to deliver them and it was
like very very very very operationalized
from day one and it's going great I
don't remember exactly uh what we're
allowed to say about how big it is but
it got to seven figures in Revenue in
like 60 days most of which came because
at first I tweeted it and then Cody
Sanchez another partner involved she
started sharing and so now it's like
well into the seven figures
um it's going great you have to deal
with a lot of headaches because it's a
people business but uh and we're not
sure how churn will be but it's going
really well so far the hardest part
about these businesses is
operationalizing the the service so
making it so it's like a conveyor belt
so your workers know exactly what to do
and have very strict deadlines and the
second hardest part is getting customers
viral Cuts solve that problem by talking
to me and Cody and we just tweeted it
out and within a very short amount of
time they had seven figures in Revenue
so it's going really well all right so
that was my rapid fire q a this is what
happens when Sean's not here we do a
little rapid fire q a hopefully you guys
enjoyed it if you are listening on
iTunes Spotify whatever if you go to our
YouTube You'll see some of the links to
some of these examples and some of these
topics that we talked about and if you
like this let me know in the comments
talk soon
[Music]
foreign